[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
روسيا تتصدى لتوغل جديد في بيرود ومعارضون
مسلحون لبوتين يعرضون تبادل اسرع مع موسكو
تصعيد يتجدد في الخرطوم والدعم السريع
يؤكد التزامه باعلان جده وحمايه المدنيين
يساعد على يعني تعزيز فرص استقرار الاسواق
ومنعه من التذبذب
الانتاج بواقع مليون واربعمائه الف برميل
يوميا والسعوديه تؤكد ان القرار سيعزز
استقرار الاسواق
ولدينا ايضا
وسط تقارير امريكيه عن عوده قويه لترامب
في الاعلام صحف تهاجم خصمه حاكم فلوريدا
[موسيقى]
من جديد تتصدر مشهد الحرب باوكرانيا وذلك
بعد اعلان الجيش الروسي احباطا محاوله
توغل جديده في المقاطعه الحدوديه قال
الجيش ان وحداتها التي تغطي الحدود في
المنطقه العسكريه الغربيه اكتشفت محاوله
مجموعه وصفها بالارهابيه والتخريبيه عبور
النهر بالقرب من منطقه نوفايا تافول جانكا
واكد الجيش الروسي انه تمكن من استهداف
المجموعه واصابتها بالمدفعيه ما ارغمها
على التراجع الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
اعلن حاكم بيلجورود
استعداده للقاء مقاتلين روس مدعومين من
اوكرانيا مقابل الافراج عن اسيرين روسيين
واشار غلاف الى انه مستعد للقاء عند حاجز
شبكيني في حال كان الاسرى لا يزالون على
قيد الحياه الا انه رجح في الوقت ذاته ان
يكون الاسرى قد قتلوا هذا وكانت مجموعه من
المقاتلين الروس المدعومين من اوكرانيا قد
اعلنت انها اثرت جنديين روسيين خلال
القتال في منطقه بلغرود وعرضت صفقه تبادل
خلال اجتماع مع حاكم المنطقه
[موسيقى]
في صوره جديده لمعادله فرض القوى بين
روسيا واوكرانيا وجهت سلطات موسكو في
منطقه شبكينو باقليم بالجورود احد معاقل
الاقتتال الدائر بين الطرفين مناشدات
للسكان للتعاون مع السلطات ومغادره
منازلهم دعوات جديه تظهر حجم القلق الروسي
من اشتداد رقعه القصف الاوكراني على
الحدود منذ اسابيع
احس القرى وخصوصا منطقه شبكيني التي تعرضت
للقصف على الاستماع لموقف السلطات
والمغادره مؤقتا من منازلهم من اجل الحفاظ
على اهم شيء وهو حياتهم وحياه المقربين
منهم
من الفوضى على الحدود بحسب مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه التي هددت بالتدخل لحمايه
بولغورود اذ لم تتصدق قوه موسكو هناك
لمحاولات كييف قلب موازين المعادله
العسكريه لصالحها والتقدم خطوه اضافيه
امام موسكو
اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع في المستقبل
القريب ما يحدث في منطقه بلغرود لان ما
يحصل هناك هو استيلاء على اراضي الاتحاد
الروسي والمنطقه لاجل هذا اشدد على اننا
سنذهب الى بالقرود لحمايه شعبنا الروسي
منطقه شابكينو باتت جزءا جديدا من خط
المواجهه مع اوكرانيا فهي واحده من
المناطق الواقعه حاليا تحت نيران كييف
كونها تبعد 10 كيلومترات فقط عن حدودها
ماذا فعل الاف من السكان الى النزوح هربا
من ضربات الموت فهذه هي الفتره الاكثر
دمويه لمناطق اقليم بالقرود منذ بدايه
الحرب بحسب الخبراء
القصف يحيل منطقه روسيه لمدينه اشباح مع
تواصل الحرب في اوكرانيا سكان مدينه
شبكينو الحدوديه يعيشون حاله من الرعب وسط
ضربات على المدينه شبيكينو التي تبعد 10
كيلومترات عن الحدود الاوكرانيه باتت جزءا
من خط المواجهه بتعرضها لقصف مدفعي بكثافه
غير مسبوقه الهجمات الاخيره سرعت اكبر
عمليه اجلاء عسكري في روسيا منذ عقود وفقا
لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز حاكم منطقه بالقرود
الروسيه اعلن اجلاء مئات الاشخاص من
السكان وتم نقلهم الى ملاجئ مؤقته في
الصالات الرياضيه بعيدا عن الحدود الانباء
الوارده من المنطقه الحدوديه تشير الى ان
الاسبوع الماضي كان الاكثر دمويه منذ
بدايه الحرب نيويورك تايمز التقت برجل
اعمال في المدينه اشار الى ان اقليه فقط
كانت تعارض الحرب في بدايتها الا ان الوضع
تغير اليوم تماما
[موسيقى]
من موسكو المحلل العسكري الروسيه اهلا بك
معنا استاذ فاضل يبدو ان المعارك تنتقل
شيئا فشيئا الى الداخل الروسي بعد موضوع
المسيرات في موسكو نحن امام عمليات مستمره
على الحدود في الجانب الروسي منها
الى اي مدى روسيا مستعده ان يستمر هذا على
حدودها في داخلها
هذا تصعيد للصراع
اعتقد ان هذا تصيد كلي مع انتقالنا في
الفتره الحاليه الى موسم قتال الصيف وهو
تصعيد على جبهات مختلفه
ونرى ان هناك مناوشات مستمره على حدود بيل
جرود
وبالاضافه الى بعض المناطق الحدوديه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه التي قد تكون البعض
منها مستقره
لفتره من الوقت لكن لقد تكون هذه
مجرد فاتحه
للمعركه الكبرى
وقد نرى ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد تسعى
لتبديد انتباه القوات الروسيه الى منطقه
الشمال التي يجري فيها الاستعداد لعمليه
هجوميه معاكسه في الجنوب اذا انتم تفهمون
هذه العمليات على الحدود على انها بدايه
فعليه للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني كما بات
يعرف اعلاميا
موسم القتال الصيف قد وصل وخاصه في منطقه
الجنوب سواء
حيث ان الاوضاع باتت مئاتيه لا نرى مزيدا
من هطول الامطار والاجواء صيفيه
وهذا امتداد للعمليات التي جرت في فصل
الربيع
نامل
ان تنهي هذه العمليه القتاليه حاله الجنود
[موسيقى]
حاله الحرب التي نراها
فهي حرب متنقله ومتحركه لذا انهم يسعون
لدفع الجنود الروسي باتجاهات مختلفه قبل
ان يحاولون اجراء اختراق بطريقه متحركه
ولكن ما قاله احد المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
منذ ايام لم يعد خيالا عندما تحدث عن حزام
امن منزوع السلاح على الحدود بين روسيا
واوكرانيا من الجانب الروسي
اعتقدنا ان ذلك ضرب من الخيال عندما قاله
الان نتحدث عن
نزوح او اجلاء سكان تلك المناطق وعن
عمليات في داخل هذه المناطق وتوغلات من
الجانب الاوكراني وبالتالي يمكن ان نتخيل
انه هذا يمكن ان يكون جزءا من اي حل
مستقبل تقبل به روسيا
نتيجه
حمله فصل الصيف تبقى مفتوحه على كافه
الاحتمالات اوكرانيا تامل في تحقيق النصر
وروسيا تتسعى لابطال هجومهم المعاكس بحيث
يمكن الاقران ذاك ان تقبل تجميد الوضع على
خطوط التحكم التي نراها في الفتره الحاليه
وقبول حاله تجميد للقتال هذه قد تكون هي
الاستراتيجيات المتبعه وكل من الطرفين سوف
يدفع باتجاه الفعلي ما يستطيع لتحقيق
اهدافه ومقاربه سوف يكون هناك المزيد من
الاقتتال في جبهات مختلفه المزيد من
الهجمات داخل اوكرانيا
وبالمقابل داخل روسيا
بحيث نصل الى فتره قد يكونوا التصعيد في
اشده على مستوى العنف مع اقتراب كل من
الطرفين لتحقيق اهدافه الاستراتيجيه في في
حمله الصيف المقبله التي قد تمتد حتى شهر
اكتوبر في اضعف الايمان خاصه مع التدريب
والسلاح المقدمين من الغرب يعني
تهيئه لما تسميها بحمله الصيف وساعود بهذا
الموضوع اليك بعد قليل استاذ بابل ارجو ان
تتفضل بالبقاء معنا بالتدريب والسلاح
المقدم من الغرب تستعد اوكرانيا لشن
هجومها المضاد الذي طال انتظاره بحسب
تقرير لواشنطن بوست الامريكيه الصحيفه
اشارت الى ان الوحدات التي دربتها وسلحتها
دول نيتو ستكون بمثابه راس الحربه في
الهجوم الاوكراني والقت الضوء على اللواء
الميكانيكي السابع والاربعين الذي تدرب
لاشهر في عده دول على التكتيكات الحربيه
الاكثر تقدما بعد انتهاء المناورات التي
قام بها اللواء الميكانيكي اذ تم لاسلحه
غربيه بما في ذلك مركبات برادلي القتاليه
ونقلت الوحده الى موقع سري اقرب الى خط
الجبهه ورات الصحيفه ان الهجوم المضاد
سيكون اوضح اختبار للاستراتيجيه التي
تقودها الولايات المتحده لمنح الاوكرانيين
الاسلحه والتدريب للقتال بشكل مماثل للجيش
الامريكي بعدما تم تدريب عشرات الاف
الجنود في عدد من دول الناتو بريطانيا على
سبيل المثال اعلنت اكمال تدريب عشره الاف
مجند اوكراني على اراضيها منذ بدء الحرب
مع اعتزامها تدريب اربعين الفا اخرين خلال
العام الجاري والكثير منهم تدربوا على
دبابات تشالنجر 2 التي تم تسليمها لكياف
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه في جانب اخر قامت
اسبانيا بدعم الاف الجنود الاوكرانيين
بالتدريب على مختلف الاسلحه بما فيها
دبابات ليوبارد في اكاديميه توليدو للمشاه
واذا انتقلنا الى المانيا التي الجنود
بالفعل على الدبابات ذاتها ليوبارد كما
انها اعلنت منتصف الشهر الماضي وصول
دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه الى المانيا
لتدريب اطقم الدبابات الاوكرانيه اخيرا
الى بولندا التي قامت بدور كبير في تدريب
الجنود الاوكرانيين على مختلف الاسلحه
والتكتيكات الى ان اعلنت قبل ايام عن
بدئها في تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على
قياده مقاتلات اف 16 بعد ضوء اخضر امريكي
لهذه الخطوه ومع التدريبات المكثفه للقوات
الاوكرانيه الا ان دعم الغربي يبقى مشروطا
بعدم استخدام هذه الاسلحه في مهاجمه
الاراضي الروسيه يعود الينا الاستاذ
المحلل العسكري الروسي من موسكو اهلا بك
مجددا الى اي مدى باعتقادك يمكن لدول
الغرب ان تضمن استمراريه الضغط على
القياده الاوكرانيه بعدم استهداف الاراضي
الروسيه
من خلال الاسلحه المقدمه غربيا اذا ثبت
للبعض عكس ذلك في الفتره الماضيه ما رايك
دي صوره رسميه تقول اوكرانيا بانها لا
تستخدم الكثير من الامدادات الغربيه من
الاسلحه
لشني هجمات داخل الاراضي
الروسيه المعترف بها دوليا
لكن الروسي يقولون بانهم لا يعتمد لا
يوافقون على تلك الاجراءات ولكن من جهه
اخرى
اوكرانيا تقول بانه يحق لها ان تفعل ما
يكون مناسبا في ظل هذا التصعد اعتقده بان
هناك حاله من التضارب في التصريحات
واوكرانيا لن تكونوا جاده
بشن بعض الهجمات التي قد تطالب داخل
الروسي
رغم ان هجمات كثيره
التي قد تحدث ضد روسيا قد لا تكون محتمله
من قبل
اوكرانيا هذه الحلقه تبقى عرضه للتغيير
والتقلب وخاصه بان الدول الغربيه
لديهم قدره تاثير كبيره على اوكرانيا واذا
ما كان هناك واذا ما غضوا الطرف عن بعض
الهجمات فان الاوكرانيين سوف يعملون اذا
ما قرر الغرب بانه قد طفح الكيل فانهم سوف
يجعلون اوكرانيا تتوقف عن تلك الهجمات
ولكن روسيا متى تقول طفح الكايل الاستاذ
فاضل فيما يتعلق بهذه الهجمات وبتدريب
والدعم والتمويل الغربيه لاوكرانيا هل
تعتقد بانه اذا استمر ذلك ونجحت اوكرانيا
في حمله الصيف كما سميتها يعني اذا استمر
ذلك
بهذه الشده وهذه الوتيره المتصاعده هل
يمكن هل لا يزال لدى القياده الروسيه
اوراق تستخدمها ضد الغرب
هناك دائما احتماليه ان نرى صيدا في هذا
الصراع
فقد يتحول هذا الصراع من صراع محلي الى
اقليميه طالب بعض الدول الاعضاء في حلف
الناتو والتحول الى حرب
عالميه كونيه بالسلاح النوويه هذا احتمال
وارد لكن في الفتره الحاليه ذلك الاحتمال
يبدو بعيده المنال
بسبب
العتبه التي قد لا تتخطاها روسيا في
استخدام السلاح النووي وكذلك لا يرغب
الغرب بفعل ذلك ان الحديث عن استخدام
الردع النووي امر وارد اما التخطي ذلك
وتخطي عتبه هذا الامر فهذا الامر قد لا
يكون ضمن النقاط المطروحه بصوره عمليه رغم
ان الاحتمالات ليست في حاله العدم وسوف
تبقى موجوده كنا نسمع من الروس بانه
استهداف العمق الروسي هو الخط الاحمر الذي
لن تسمح روسيا بتجاوزه وان حصل قد تستخدم
كل قوتها بما فيها النووي ونسمع تهديدات
من بعض المسؤولين الروس على راسهم في هذا
الشان ثم لا يحصل شيء ما هو الخط الاحمر
حقيقه عند الروس
نائب رئيس رئيس الوزراء السابق والرئيس
السابق هو لم يعد مسؤولا عن القوات
العسكريه فهو يتحدث
عن تهديدات هذا صحيح
وهذا يسمى رضع النووي
هذه هي التي يمكن من خلالها للاسلحه
النوويه ان تستخدم للتهديد ولا يمكن
استخدامها بصوره حقيقيه ولا اعتقد ان هذا
الامر هو الشيك الحدوث نعم من اجل الرضع
هو من اجل ردع الغرب
لتزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه الاكثر لكن تجاوز العتبه النووي لا
اعتقد ان هذا امر وشيك الحدود شكرا جزيلا
لك من موسكو المحلل العسكري
تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
وبعد الفصل المتابع موضوعا كان من احد
تداعيات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه عندما
بدا من اسطنبول امين عام الناتو يدعو
اردوغان الى رفع فيتو تركيا عن انضمام
السويد للحلف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تواصلت الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع في عده
مناطق بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مع
تركزها في شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري
وتزامنت الاشتباكات مع قصف جوي نفذه سلاح
الجو السوداني على المدينه مصحوبا بقصف
مدفعي من قاعده كرري وافاد سكان ام درمان
بسماع اصوات اطلاق نار ودوي اسلحه خفيفه
ومتوسطه مع تحليق لطيران الاستطلاع
والمروحيات في سماء المدينه التي تشهد
انقطاعا للتيار الكهربائي جراء المواجهات
[موسيقى]
الى ذلك قلى قائد قوه الدعم السريع
السودانيه محمد حمدان دقلو انه اكد في
اتصال مع وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان دعمه لمنبر جده والتزامه
باعلان حمايه المدنيين وتسهيل ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه واضاف دجلوفي بيان
انه ناقش مع وزير الخارجيه السعوديه لو
ضاع في السودان وجهود الوساطه فضلا عن
تبادل وجوهات النظر حول اخر التطورات في
البلاد واضاف حميتي تاكيده على اهميه
التنسيق وتكثيف الجهود المشتركه من اجل
تحقيق الاستقرار في السودان وفق البيان
معنى من الخرطومه صحفيه عمار ابو شيبه
اهلا بك يبدو ان الاشتباكات مستمره بين
الطرفين عمار
اهلا بك طاهر اهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام نعمل
اشتباكات مستمره منذ اكثر من نصف ساعه هنا
في منطقه شرق العاصمه الخرطوم في منطقه
بري حيث نستمع لعدد من الانفجارات
والمدفعيه المتبادله ما بين الطرفين الدعم
السريع يتواجد في منطقه بري والجيش في
منطقه القياده يفصلهما الشارع فقط هذا
الشارع معروف باسم عبيد ختم ويقود مباشره
هذا الشارع الى جسر كوبر الذي يقع في
المنتصف هذه المنطقه هذه الاشتباكات طاهر
تدور منذ اكثر من نصف ساعه هنالك ايضا
انذارات على
وهبوب عاصفه جويه وامطار وبالمقابل ايضا
الاشتباكات تدور ما بين الطرفين في هذه
المنطقه هنالك رد ورد
متبادل طوال هذه الفتره بالمدفعيه الثقيله
والاسلحه الرشاشه وعدد من الدانات التي
نسمعها بين فتره واخرى منطقه بري هي منطقه
سكنيه
هجر سكان هذه المنطقه بشكل كبير اصبحت
الان مدن اشباح بشكل واضح تجولنا فيها قبل
عده ايام ولمسنا وشاهدنا ذلك بشكل مباشر
الجيش يتواجد في الجانب الشرقي من القياده
العامه يرد على القذائف التي تاتي من
منطقه بوري وبالجانب الاخر هنالك رد هذه
الاشتباكات طاهر تمركزت بشكل واضح في هذه
المنطقه وتحولت منذ النهار عده مناطق اخرى
في العاصمه الخرطوم الى الجبهات قتال خاصه
في الاطراف في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم هنالك
عدد من الاشتباكات وقصفا جويا تم لعدد من
الاحياء بحسب معلومات وردت الينا من مصادر
الطبيه غير الرسميه محليه اشارت الى سقوط
عدد من الضحايا في منطقه حي العشرة بجنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم وايضا سقوط عدد من
القذائف في منطقه مايو جنوب الخرطوم وايضا
احياء الازهري في هذه المنطقه مدينه بحري
شمالا دارت فيها عدد من الاشتباكات
واتحدثت الدعم السريع عن انه
طائره تابعه للجيش السوداني كانت قد قصفت
وهاجمت عدد من تمركزاته بالمنطقه الجيش لم
يعلق على هذه النقطه حتى الان ولم يبين
سبب سقوط الطائره او اذا ما سقطت بالفعل
بفعل المضادات الارضيه التابعه للدعم
السريع مدينه ام درمان طاهره بارد فيها
عدد من الاشتباكات غربا وجنوبا في محيط
الاذاعه والتلفزيون ومدرمان القديمه وعدد
من الاحياء الاخرى هذا يقودنا بشكل واضح
للعوده الى المربع الاول والذي هو عوده
الاشتباكات العنيفه وهنالك عده ربما الى
معظم المناطق الرئيسيه في الخرطوم شكرا
جزيلا لك صحفي عمر ابو شيبه من الخرطوم
تحياتي اليك في نشرات لاحقه ان شاء الله
وبالتزامن مع عوده تصعيد الى الخرطوم شهدت
مدينه كتب في شمال دارفور مواجهات اسفرت
عن مقتل مدنيين ياتي ذلك فيما نفى الجيش
السوداني سيطره الدعم السريع على المدينه
واظهرت مقاطع مصوره حصلت عليها العربيه
تصاعدا كفيفا لاعمده الدخان مع استمرار
الاشتباكات في شوارع المدينه وسط مخاوف من
اتساع الصراع وتحوله الى اقتتال قبلي من
جانبه اعلن حاكم دارفور الاقليم منطقه
منكوبه مع استمرار اعمال النهب والقتل
مشيرا الى ان المدنيين يتعرضون في
مدينتينا لانتهاكات مروعه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل مقداد ان
بلاده تدين ما وصفه بالاعتداءات التركيه
التي تطال بلاده والعراق ودعا خلال مؤتمر
صحفي مع نظيره العراقي في بغداد الى ضروره
وقف دعم التنظيمات الارهابيه الموجوده في
سوريا
نحن ضد الاعتداءات التي تتم سواء داخل
الاراضي العراقيه وندين هذه الاعتداءات
ونطالب بوقفها او الدعم الذي يقدم
للمجموعات الارهابيه المسلحه في بعض
المناطق في سوريا وخاصه
لجبهه النصره داعش كما ذكرت هذا يجب ان
يتوقف
وستكون له تفاعلات كثيره
اذا
استمر لان البلدين قادرين على التنسيق
فيما بينهما بينهما لمواجهه هذه التحديات
حكومه تركيا جديده اعلن عنها الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان يوم امس مع ادائه اليمين
الدستوريه مع بدايه ولايته الثالثه رئيسا
التغيير طالب معظم الحقائب الوزاريه التي
لم يبقى منها الا وزيره الصحه والسياحه
وهما الوزيران الوحيدان المستقلين في
الحكومه وغير المنتميين لحزب العداله
والتنميه في جانب اخر برزت اسماء جديده
تولت حقائب سياديه والحديث هنا الخارجيه
التي تسلمها هاكان فيدان والدفاع وعلى
راسها رئيس الاركان السابق يشار جولر
بينما تولى علي ييرلكايا وزاره الداخليه
الوزارات الثلاثه التي تحدثنا عنها
الخارجيه والدفاع والداخليه من المتوقعه
ان تلعب دورا كبيرا في الملف السوري الى
جانب جهاز الاستخبارات وزير الخارجيه
الجديد هكان فيدان بصفته رئيسا
للاستخبارات سابقا كان له دور في قياده
عمليه المحادثات الاستخباريه مع الحكومه
السوريه كما نذكر والتي وصلت لاحقا الى
مستويات ارفع على صعيد الوزراء الدفاع
والخارجيه برعايه روسيه من المتوقع ان
يعمل فيدان بالتنسيق مع وزاره الدفاع
وجهاز الاستخبارات على معالجه البعدين
الامني والعسكري في سوريا مع استبعاد
تركيا الانسحاب من الشمال السوري والعمل
على محاربه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه هذا عن
الجانب الدبلوماسي ممثلا بوزاره الخارجيه
اما في المجال الامني فيبرز دور يشار
جولار في حقيبه الدفاع الان فهو رئيس
الاركان السابق كما ذكرنا والمقرب من سلفه
خلص
لكن بقاء جولر فتره طويله في ظل اداره
اثار القويه لن يعني بحسب محللين ان يكون
له دور ثانوي في معالجه الملف السوري مع
توقعات بان يعمل جولار في هذا الملف
بالتنسيق بشكل مباشر مع اردوغان
والان الى ملف اللاجئين السوريين ودور
وزاره الداخليه بطبيعه الحال حيث ستكون
لدى الوزير علير لكايا صلاحيه واسعه فيما
يتعلق بملف السوريين الذين يقيمون في
تركيا تحت بند الحمايه المؤقته ويبدو ان
الوزير لكايا جمع خبره تراكميه خاصه في ظل
قربه من سلفه سليمان
وبعد حضوره المباشر لعمليه تنظيم وجود
السوريين في اسطنبول التي كان واليا سابقا
عليها وبعد اطلاعه على الدق حيث ياتي هذا
الملف
اذا خمس سنوات مقبله من حكم اردوغان ربما
لا تحمل ما يشي بحل كامل للملف السوري
بجانبيه الخارجي والداخلي بالنسبه لانقره
الا انها قد تشهد حلحله جزئيه قائمه على
مساري التطبيع مع دمشق والعمل في ان واحد
على محاوله تخفيف الوجود السوري داخل
تركيا معنى من اسطنبول دكتور مهند حافظ
اوغلو الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي اهلا بك
معنا دكتور ومن دمشق معنا عمر رحمون
المتحدث باسم المصالحه السوريه اهلا بك
معنا استاذ عمر يعني انا اريد ان ابدا
بالملف من الجانب التركي من حيث التغييرات
التي حصلت في تركيا دكتور الى اي مدى
تعتقد انه سيكون لها تاثيرات وانه وضع
شخصيه مثل هاكان فيدان في الخارجيه يمكن
ان تعني ازاحه الوجوه القديمه وفتح صفحه
جديده كليا لتركيا فيما يتعلق ببعض
الملفات وعلى راسها الملف السوري نحو
المزيد من التطبيع ما رايك
وجميع المشاهدين طبعا عندما يكون حكام في
دان وزيرا للخارجيه ربما ينطلق من المنطلق
الذي تفضلت به وهو الامني والاستخبارات اي
الميدان هو من يحكم المسارات المستقبليه
لا اريد ان اقول ان
الوزير الحالي سوف يكون
سيصل الى مستوى التصادم او الاستظام او
ولكنها وزاره قاسيه وزاره قويه وزاره صلبه
وزاره تاتي من خلفيه امنيه بشكل وباللباس
سياسي اليوم حكام في دار 13 سنه وهو ماسك
للاستخبارات التركيه يعرف كل التفاصيل وهو
من ضمن من يصنعون الامني واستخباراتي في
تركيا وبالتالي
وزيرا للخارجيه هذا يعني الميدان هو من
سوف يحكم اي مسار تفاوضى سياسي وفي عدد من
النقاط تعود بها اليك ولكن دعنا نرى
الموقف من عند استاذ عمر رحم ون هل يعني
لديكم نفس الفهم لموضوع هذه التغييرات
التي حصلت في الحقائب الوزاريه في تركيا
وبالتالي فعلا الاتجاه سيكون في هذا
الاطار وتم الاتفاق على بعض بنوده ام انه
الطريق لا تزال طويله
مساء الخير للجميع يعني نحن في سوريا هناك
شك وريبه
سواء حاول مره اخرى مع الاستاذ عمر
الو انا طيب
اسمعك اسمعك جيدا الان تفضل طيب طيب نحن
في سوريا في الحقيقه من خلال التجربه خلال
عشر سنوات او من خلال تجربه 400 سنه سابقه
ننظر بعين الريبه والشك من اي تطور في
تركيا نتمنى ان يكون نحو الافضل لكن
الريبه والشك هي الشعور السائد في سوريا
حول اي تطور يجري في تركيا مما لا شك فيه
بان حقان رئيس الاستخبارات التركيه هو من
سعى لاطلاق المصالحه السوريه التركيه لحتى
اكون دقيقا حقا هو من سعى وراءها وهو من
اشتغل عليها وهم اشتغلت في الخفاء لحتى
ينطلق هذا المركب وفي تقدير
تعويم هذا الشخص تعويم حقه فداء من
المخابرات السريه ورجل الظل الى العلم هو
فيه اكثر من رساله وبيده اكثر من مفتاح
سياسي لملفات داخليه وخارجيه ومنها الملف
السوري انا في تقديري سيشهد الولد في
السوري دفع نحو الام لان حتى فدان يحمل
الان في في حقيبته شحنه نحو المصالحه نحو
اللقاء مع الجانب السوري لحل المشاكل هناك
مشكله اللاجئين مشكله الاحتلال التركي
مشكله المياه وقطع المياه عن سوريا من
مياه الفرات ودجله
حزب العملاء الكردستاني ساعود ببعض هذه
النقاط بعد قليل ولكن دعني اخذ رد الاستاذ
الدكتور مهند على موضوع الريبه والشك
السوريين الذين تحدث عنهما ضيفنا الكريم
قبل قليل من اي تحرك تركي ما رايك
ليس بالجديد يعني اذا كان وزير الخارجيه
السوري من بغداد ومن موسكو يضع العصي في
عجلات هذا الطريق هذا الامر واضح من ان
دمشق لا تريد لهذا التقارب ولهذا المسار
ان يستمر وان يصل وان يتوج الى تعاون
حقيقي ميداني تحاول دمشق ان تركز على
المسار السياسي وان تذهب نحو التفاصيل اما
لماذا ترى انه يضع العصير في الدواليب اذا
كان يدين ما يسميها بالاعتداءات التركيه
على بلاده وعلى اراضيه وعلى سيادتها
يا سيدي القوات الارهابيه الموجوده شمال
سوريا سواء في ادلب جبهه النصره هي جاءت
لتعاون تركي امريكي وحتى قوات قصد التي
تعتبرها تركيا قوات ارهابيه سيطرت على 600
كيلو متر بين على الحدود السوريه التركيه
يعني لو كان جار قصد يتعرض لما استطعت ان
تسيطر القصد على 600 كيلو متر وتركيا تنظر
الى هذه القوات تتمدد على الحدود في
جوارها يعني هذه الشعارات والكلام الذي
يقال في تركيا يعني لم نعد لم يعد الواقع
يقبله اذا كانت تركيا تريد حسن علاقات مع
سوريا واذا ارادت تركيا ان تنطلق هذه
المصالحه السوريه التركيه لابد من تطبيق
هذا الكلام الواقع الوجود التركي في
الشمال السوري هو احتلال ولا شيء اخر لا
عمليه جراحيه جراحيه ممن اذا كانوا يريدون
طرد الارهاب فجبهه النصره هم من يمولونها
وهم من يدعمونها لنكن واقعيين صرنا 13 سنه
بنقول هذا بيدعم وهذا بيقدم وهذا باخر
لابد من الاتفاق على طرد الخط الاحمر في
هذا الاطار واضح استاذ دكتور مهند يجب على
تركيا ان تسحب قواتها وان توقف دعمها
للفصائل التي تدعمها في سوريا كي تعود
الدولتان الى مبادئ حسن الجوار
مره اخرى نعود لسيد حكان في دان يعني
عندما نقول الارهاب يجب ان نصل الى تعاريف
مشترك ولا نقطه اتحاد مشتركه ننطلق منها
كل من انقره ودمشق الى محاربه الارهاب هل
تستطيع دمشق بان تقول بان قصد مجموعات
ارهابيه تستولي وتحتل ربع الاراضي السوريه
الجغرافيه السوريه اتستطيع دمشق ان تقول
ان قصد محتله لبعض من جغرافيا السوريه كما
تحتل اسرائيل بعضا من الجغرافيا السوريه
في الجولان اذا لم نعتبر ان قست مجموعات
ارهابيه يجب محاربتها وليست مجموعات
انفصاليه ويمكن من خلال الحوار الوصول
معها الى حل خلفها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك من يدربها حتى من من قوات
ايرانيين وبالتالي تركيا ليست بعيده عن
الواقع وهي تعلم تماما ماذا يجري اما فيما
يتعلق بجبهه النصره فتركيا لن تدعم النصره
هي في ادلب ولديها قاعده شعبيه ولديها
احتضان شعبي تركيا لا تركيا كل ما يعنيها
في كل هذا الملف هو عشرين ميلان مسافه
امنه هل تستطيع دمشق وموسكو وطهران ان
تؤمن لانقره هذه العشرين ميلا اربع خمس
سنوات حتى هذه اللحظه ولا جدوى لاي
تحركم
من الداخل السوري المتمثل بالقوات الكرديه
والطرف الاخر ايضا لديه ما يقول انه ارهاب
يؤذيه وتدعمه تركيا ردك على هذا الكلام
استاذ عمر
اذا لم تقتنع تركيا ليس عندنا مشكله في
سوريا ان نقول بان قصد ارهابيه وهو مرتزق
وعملاء لامريكا وهم يحتلون المنطقه
الشرقيه ويسرقون النفط ولكن لو تابات
الالام الرسمي لرايت كل يوم هناك على كل
الوسائل الاعلام السوريه الرسميه ادانات
وتوصيف لهذه لهذه لهذه القوات بانها
مرتزقه وتابعه لامريكا وقوات انفصاليه
وتريد الانشقاق وتريد تشكيل كانتون كردي
وتريد الانفصال عن سوريا يعني لكن هل
يستطيع اردوغان لان يقول بان الجيش الوطني
هو جيش عميله بان هذه القوات الارهابيه
التي يدعمها تدعمها تركيا وتنقلها من
ليبيا الى اذربيجان ينبغي ان نصل الى نقطه
الى نقطه واحده وانت تتلاقى الدولتان لا
امن قوم تركي محفوظ بدون سوريا ولا امن
قومي سوري محفوظ بس شو الحلول الوسط اللي
عم تناقش بهذا الاطار يبدو انه الافكار لا
تزال يعني مشتته
ومتطرفه بين قوسين يعني ليس هناك
الكثير من الخطوط الوسط بينكما في
افكاركما ما الحلول الوسط التي يمكن ان
تنتج عن اي لقاءات مقبله فيما يتعلق
باللاجئين بحزب العمال الكردستاني بالوجود
التركي في سوريا دكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو
يعني يا استاذ طهر اذا بدا حواره هو حديثه
فيما يتعلق بالتشكيك وعدم الثقه بالجانب
التركي هنا مشكله حقيقيه اذا نحن في ازمه
ثقه اذا كانت لدى دمشق ازمه ثقه حقيقيه
تجاه انقره
صالح مع ايران
يعني لماذا تذهب اذا هو هذا المسار يعني
اذا كان هناك عدم الثقه هذه فاذا المسار
كله
وجوده او عدمه السيان يعني لماذا لا تكون
الثقه هي المنبع اما التركيز في الاعلام
وعلى المصطلحات وهنا اركز على كلمه
المصطلحات في غايه الاهميه الاحتلال
التركي الارهاب التركي احتلال الجغرافيه
التركيه
وتاريخ الامن القومي السوري والامن القومي
العراقي من قبل الاجانب التركي هذه
المفردات اذا لم تزل او تلغى من قبل
الاعلام في دمشق او في بغداد نحن في ازمه
حقيقيه ولا نصل الى ما شفت انه تصريح وزير
الخارجيه اليوم يعني اجا بوقت شوي كان
البعض بيعتقد انه الامور رايحه على تهدئه
حتى يعني توقع الشخصي لموضوع المقابله هذه
كان انه تكون اهدا من هيك بس يبدو الامور
بعدها يعني القلوب مليانه مثل ما بيقول
استاذ طاهر انا مع المسارحه وانا متحدث
باسم مصالحه وانا ما اشتغلت على اطلاق
المصالحه السوريه التركيه وهذا شيء يعني
ليس محل بحثي الان لكن انا في تقديري
التصريحات السوريه هي اقل مما يمكن توقعه
بكثير يعني الدوله تحتل ارضك وتخترق
سيادتك وتشارك بتدمير جيشك وبردك ماذا
تتوقع ان يكون الخطاب في الاعلام او حتى
الخطاب السياسي هناك محددات وضعها السيد
الرئيس بشار الاسد لاسرائيل كما وضعها
لتركيا كما وضعها لامريكا لا يمكن تطبيع
بين اسرائيل وسوريا الا بانسحاب اسرائيل
من الجولان لا يمكن التطبيع الكامل مع
تركيا الا بانسحاب الجيش التركي من الشمال
السوري ولا يمكن التطبيع العلاقات بين
سوريا وامريكا سحب القوات الامريكيه من
الشرق السوري هذا شيء لا نقاش حوله شكرا
جزيلا لكما دكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو
الاكاديمي والبحث السياسي من اسطنبول من
دمشق عمر رحمون المتحدث باسم المصالحه
السوريه شكرا جزيلا لك كذلك
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وصفها كان
فيدان في تصريح سابق بانه صندوق اسراره
دعونا نتعرف اكثر على وزير الخارجيه
التركيه الجديد
[موسيقى]
وزير الخارجيه التركي الجديد هاكان فدان
تخرج من المدرسه الحربيه للقوات البريه
واكمل تعليمه الجامعي اثناء خدمته في
الجيش التركي توجه للحياه الاكاديميه في
عدد من الجامعات بعد خدمته في الجيش تولى
مناصب مهمه في مجالات السياسه الخارجيه
والامن على مستويات حكوميه مختلفه كان
مسؤولا عن سياسه الخارجيه وقضايا الامن في
رئاسه الوزراء شغل منصب نائب رئيس جهاز
الاستخبارات التركيه في ابريل من عام 2010
في الشهر التالي تولى رئاسه جهاز
الاستخبارات ل 13 عاما حتى تم تكليفه
بحقيبه وزاره الخارجيه
هاكان فيدان هو صندوق اسراري وصف اطلقه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على فيدان
قبل اعوام
[موسيقى]
في تركيا ولكن في شان اخر دعا الامين
العام لحلف شمال الاطلس انقره الى التخلي
عن معارضتها لمسعد سويد للانضمام الى
الحلف وقال السويد اوفت بالتزاماتها واتخذ
واتخذت خطوات ملموسه مهمه لتلبيه المخاوف
التركيه
[موسيقى]
اتخذت السويد خطوات ملموسه ومهمه لتلبيه
مخاوف تركيا ويشمل ذلك تعديل الدستور
السويدي وانهاء حظر الاسلحه المفروضه
عليها وتكثيف التعاون في مكافحه الارهاب
بما في ذلك ضد حزب العمال الكردستاني وقد
دخل قانون مكافحه الارهاب الجديد حيز
التنفيذ قبل ايام قليله فقط لذا اوفت
السويد بالتزاماتها
[موسيقى]
نعود اليكم بعد هذا الفصل فارجو ان
تتفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ننتقل الى فيينا مع
الزميل ناصر الطيبي وهذه المقابله الخاصه
التي اجراها مع الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان وزير الطاقه السعودي
سمو الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان شكرا لك
على اتاحتك الفرصه هنا في فيينا
التخفيض الطوعي السعودي لنبدا به لانه
لربما الاقرب زمنيا ضمن سلسله القرارات
التي اتخذها او تم اتخاذها مساء هذا اليوم
مليون برميل يوميا لشهر يوليو طبعا ليست
اول مره تنفرد بها السعوديه في هذه
التخفيضات الطوعيه حدثنا اكثر عن القرار
وراء هذا التخفيض تحديدا لشهر يوليو وهل
سيكون كافي لدرء الرهانات من المضاربين
على انخفاض الاسعار برايك
احنا ما عندنا عقده مضاربين يمكن في
منحاول يدفع بهذا الكثير لكن
هي زي اللي مارسناها في عام 21
اعتقد انه كل الاجراءاتنا الاخيره حتى في
شهر ابريل تخفيض اللي سوت الدول المشاركه
معنا
لمنفرده سويتك كقرار منفرد لكل دوله هو
قرار تحوطي
واعتقد انه
في ظل الظروف الراهنه كان في حاجه لاتخاذ
اجراء اضافي لكن تقديرنا هو انه في كان
بتكون صعوبات على دول لم نتواصل مع احد
لكن لانه حتى الدول القادره على التخفيض
كان لهم تخفيض في ابريل لسه بادي نتائج
المفروض نشوف تقييم النتائجها في في منتصف
يونيو
جميعا توافقنا معهم على تمديد هذه
التخفيضات التوعيه الى نهايه 24 وهذا كميه
مضافه يعني لا ننسى ان مليون وسبع مئه الف
واستمرارها لمده
سنه ونص تقريبا اي واحد يحسبها بكم حجم
الكميات البترول يمكن والله ما اعتقد يعني
ما حاول تحسبها لكن سهله الحسب لكن نعتقد
انه انيا نسوق ايضا بحاجه لتطمنات
او اجراء تحوطي يعزز الموثوقيه في انه فيه
من هو قادر بعد مشيه الله انه يعني يتحوط
او يحوط السوق باجراءات اضافيه
تمنع
من انه يتعرض الى تذبذبات سبحان الله بعض
الجهات عشان ما نسميه
يعتقدون حتى بشيء كان في شيء من التحكم
انه يعني السعوديه تنظر للتذبذبات من جهه
واحده فقط شرحتها في المؤتمر الصاحب من
شوي لانه احنا كدوله منتجه
وتاخذ في اعتبارها المدى الطويل
ليس انا لنا مصلحه في تذبذبات قصيره المدى
او متوسطه المدى او حتى طويله المدى
هذا امر غير مقبول لبعض المنتفعين ولذلك
نعتقد انه علينا واجب انه نعزز
استقرار واستدامه هذه الاستقرار الاسواق
البتوليه لان هذا معزز لاستقرار صناعه
البترول وبالتالي
وليست فقط
للمملكه لكن كافه الدول الاوبك بلس وايضا
الدول المنتجه والصناعه
سمو الامير ذكرت بانه اجراء تحوطي
واحترازي بالنظر الى قرارات اليوم كان
هناك جزء كبير من هذه القرارات فيما يخص
عام 20 24 هل الصوره سلبيه برايكم الى هذه
الدرجه التي دفعتكم لاتخاذ هذه الاجراءات
المحوطيه احنا علينا واجب
نحاول نكون يعني مجددين
ما لا اريد ان اصفها بمبدعين لكن مجددين
في عمليه
اعطاء السوق صوره
مستقبليه طويله
وباليات واضحه
تعبنا من تعطيه دول الحصص ما هي قادره
تنتجها
تعبنا من
ادعاءات انه هنا هذه دوله تقدر كذا وتقدر
تنشف فقلنا افضل وسيله
لمعالجه الامور هذه اللي يسمونها
بالانجليزي
انه عندك منظور او مدى واضح
تتصرف هذا المدى يتعزز عندما تكون الياتك
منضبطه باجراءات تمكن من تعزيز الموثوقيه
فيها يعني في موضوع الانتاج مراقبه
الانتاج احنا نعتمد على سبع مصادر
الان اللي سويناه جديد هو انه في بعض
الدول
رات انه ما
سوف تنتجوا في عام 24 يمكن يكون اعلى شوي
فقلنا لهم على الرحب والسعد في ثلاث جهات
دوليه معروفه
مستقله اذا اقرت انه انتاجكم ممكن يصل الى
هذه المستويات في 24 نعالج رقمكم اللي
وافق عليه اليوم
الاهم الحقيقه هو المعالجه الابديه لموضوع
الحصص
والانتاج المرجعي وهذا
والانتاج المرجع هو ان ايضا بنعتمد على
الجهه الثلاث انه من هنا من بدايه العام
24 الى منتصف 24 كل دول اوبك بلس بما في
ذلك المملكه عشان
لا يفسر هذا انه شيء من الاعتداد او شيء
من
التعالي انما قلنا لازم ابدا بنفسك هذا
قاعده تبدا بنفسك هو اعتقد هو محقق
العداله ان كل دول اوبك بلس تروح لها
المصادر الجهه المستقله
تعطيه كل المعلومات المطلوبه بحيث انها
تتاكد انه والله الارقامها فيما سوف تنتجه
خمسه وعشرين
هو فنيا سليم وصحيح وممكن ان تصادق عليه
هذا يعفينا من الجدليه الداخليه في في كل
مناشط كل يعني
اجهزه المنظمه او اللجان المنظمه لانه
بتاخذ الطابع
الغير يعني بقضيه المفاوضات اكثر من انها
تقييم فني يراعي
معايير فنيه واضحه سمو الامير هل تعتقد
بانه هذه الاليه والاعتماد على
المراقبين المستقلين
ستنظف الدفاتر من البراميل الورقيه غير
الحقيقيه هذا الاصل هذا الاصل
وليس هناك وسيله متاحه الان
الا الاعتماد على جهاد مستقله
مشهود بالموثوقيه
وهذا الادعاء لانه لا ندخل انفسنا في انه
يتحول موضوع الى انا عشت لفترات السابقه
في الثمانينات التسعينات وكانت في نهايه
المطاف الحصص وما سوف ينتج هو عمليه
تفوضيه اكثر من انها عمليه تستند على
جوانب فنيه دقيقه ولا موضوعيه سؤال الاخير
سمو الامير تقييمكم لمستويات الانتاج
الروسي والتزامهم خاصه بالحديث بانه يعني
الامدادات الروسيه وصادراتها الى الصين
الى الاسواق العالميه قد تكون منفصله
حقيقه على ارض الواقع من مستويات الانتاج
يعني بغض النظر عن مستويات الانتاج
الامدادات الروسيه ما زالت قويه بالرغم من
العقوبات لهذا كله كلام الناس انت
تتابع يمكن اكثر مني
ما ينشر وكذا يعني خلينا نركز على الجانب
الموضوعي اكثر من الجانب
الغير موضع الجانب الموضوعي انه احنا الى
الان لا نعرف كم انتجت روسيا في مايو لانه
المصادر السبع لم تنشر معلوماتها الا
تقريبا بنص يونيو
كان لنا نقاش مع
روسيا والجانب الروسي في انه عليكم
مسؤوليه في انكم تكون واضحين تكون
وشفافين في اعطاء المعلومات ثم اخذوا من
فتره قرار بعدم نشر معلومات اعتقد انه
الان يعرفون انه عدم نشر المعلومات
ادى الى ظهور هذه الظاهره الجديده من
التشكيك في معلومات ارقامهم وكذا انما
الحقيقه الان وقدام الملا يعني في المؤتمر
الصحفي ذكرت لاربع جهات من الجهات اللي من
السبع الجهات اللي نعتمد عليها في عمليه
تقييم الارقام الشهريه انه تواصلوا معاهم
اعطوهم معلومات اضافيه ذكرهم بعض الجوانب
اللي يعتقدون كان فيها خلل او خطا
والاضافه الى ذلك
التزموا انه يتواصلوا معهم شهريا للتثبت
فعشان كذا بتلقى في الاتفاق حطينا انه
انتاج فبراير روسيا هو جالس يعاد النظر
فيه من اربع من الجهات
السبع في ثلاث جهات لظروف الحظر وكذا هي
غير قادره على التواصل مع الجانب الروسي
لكن قلنا اذا كان فيه تعديل لشهر فبراير
من خلال اخذ معدل مره اخرى ارقام الجهه
السبع بافتراض انه اي من الاربع جهات راح
تعدل شيء
بيؤخذ فيه وهذا فيه عداله
للجميع وايضا بشعنا في ممارستنا هذه مع
روسيا عززنا مفهوم الشفافيه
فيما يتعلق بانتاجه شكرا جزيلا لك اسمه
الامير وعلى اتاحتكم لنا هذه الفرصه هنا
اختمها العربيه 360 ونتوجه مباشره الى
ميسون مؤيد ومع اخبار الساعه ارى انكم
تبداون بالسودان ملفا اول ليله مساء الخير
طاهر طبعا هناك اشتباكات عنيفه في السودان
ايضا سنتابع قرار بتخفيض الانتاج بالاضافه
الى تطورات الروسيه وايضا هيئه التفاوض
المعارضه في سوريا تتحدث عن ان الوقت اصبح
مناسبا
لاستئناف المفاوضات المباشره بالاضافه الى
العديد من الاخبار نامل ان تتابعنا معك
ميسون تفضلي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات